it's so strange that like comedy is I
don't want to sound like some pundit no
comedy's like always get hey that joke's
offensive hey you said hey you
said this and you're like well we also
watch
pedophile serial killer documentaries
constantly right popcorn yeah like
they're like the Michael Jackson Doc is
out I'm like I don't want to watch that
I couldn't watch it I couldn't watch it
either they pull the kid's ass the ass
cheeks
why are you this is your entertainment
but then if I say homo on stage I'm I'm
the Public Enemy Number One right it's
weird it's wacky our priorities are all
out of whack I also think that the
Michael Jackson thing I already thought
he was guilty I don't need to watch it
yeah like if I thought he was innocent
okay then maybe it's important because
it can convert me but like didn't 90 of
the world already like it's Michael
Jackson we knew he was doing up
yeah yeah man the music's great you
know like R Kelly the music's good uh
Kevin Spacey's a hell of an actor he
makes a decent sub you know if this
product is good it's good I can separate
Subway's lowest on that yeah